my name is caroline brisset i am an
artist all the way to metal and
i was chosen to create a
monumental sculpture on the forecourt of
the roland garros stadium in paris
[Music]
i have been working in metal for 18 years i have
been under 2
i always painted and drew
a lot cost g1 resumed my studies in
fine arts later and there i took a
lot longer to unlearn
what i had learned and modify my
technique to transgress it and at the
coincidence as I had a diploma in
metalwork served I was hired by
the school to supervise students in
their projects so I had the keys to
the workshop and I believe that I spent
five years locked in this workshop
closed sculpture it was really this
period that was a key moment in
my work of expression
the common thread in my work is
the material and I work a lot
with dreams always been a bit dreamlike
and roland garros it  was a dreamer at least
that's what I perceive  Hear from my readings,
all the same, being a bit crazy to
say to yourself at the time, I'm going to release them to you,
something both humble calm
and this madness of grandeur you can feel
in his eyes is always a little
lost in the clouds
he  there is a poetry that these windfalls of all
that
[Music]
my grandfather léon brisset was an
aviator he was part of the same
rice stopover that we had him garros
descarie storks
so it was quite incredible that I was
offered to work  on this subject and I
couldn't refuse
it immediately resonated very strongly
for me if movement is going to talk about it
it's a beautiful story
I first proposed very
instinctive sketches and a note of intent
and then  actually a surprise and
sent me an e-mail that fell from the sky they say to me
good here it is in fact it's you we chose
your project and there I fell from the clouds
because I was doubly
not expecting it I found myself  at the time of
construction of the sculpture of roland
garros with u  n the
tissot troop lifting equipment workshop
I had not taken into account the size
and weight of this structure and I was
welcomed by the générik vapor team
as an arena and therefore générik vapor
introduced me to the south side and  I was
welcomed by the supervising workshops which
are super well equipped where the age and
spaced
out technicians around who also help me
enormously it's really a
big family and also moral
and technical support
which is not usual for  me to have to
ask engineers to look
into a structure caroline was
not used to making
monumental statues in this kind
of environment with the public so it was
necessary to secure the statue made
from calculation notes to demonstrate the
wind resistance we actually provided caroline
with plans so that they could
respect the proportions of the statue
because imagine now there I am
really in the phase of inventions
of inspiration and that asks me a lot
of  concentration is forced to make a
mistake
to be in the right it must be
four times that I make a nose and
then in fact it's not going so I do
n't hesitate I take it off and then like firm
that's why this  that phase of
production it takes a lot of
time
I consider it a performance
with its share of great joy then
great disasters of disillusionment and
then surprises and all that in
a very short time
I know I'm lucky  to have
the opportunity to work on such a
beautiful theme was a big
challenge and then on top of that it stirs
things up with a
very strong family history